well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
then we'll see what's making the
headlines with the editor of the
sheffield star
nancy fielder and the chief executive of
conservative home
mark wallace super to see both hello as
ever to the front pages
first of all let's start with the
guardian it leads on the news that
nicolas sturgeon has been cleared of
breaking the ministerial code
scotland's first minister is also on the
front of the preston journal which says
she is relieved at the watchdogs verdict
the irish prime minister has backed
downing street over the eu's threat to
block
vaccine exports to the uk that's the
lead story
for the eye the metro leading with the
clinical trial
in the u.s which showed the oxford
astrazeneca jab caused no serious side
effects and was
very effective sheffield star marks a
year of the pandemic
in the uk also marking that milestone
the sun
says boris johnson has vowed to end
lockdown
once and for all the mirror says britain
is facing the threat of a catastrophic
third wave of covid19 infections
the daily mail claims people face fines
of 5 000 pounds
for trying to go on holidays abroad from
next monday
with france set to be added to the red
list
and a warning that all of europe may
follow
the times carries the same story with
news that the
foreign travel ban has been extended
until
july the telegraph says
care home staff face compulsory
vaccination
under a new government plan and the ft
reports on the western sanctions imposed
against china
over its treatment of uyghur muslims so
let's talk more nancy fielder and mark
wallace are here
um perhaps we'll try and squeeze in both
the uh the mail and the times which came
in a little bit later about those
foreign holidays which i know some
people are interested in but
plenty of reflection nancy on
the year that was um with the
anniversary of the announcement of that
first lockdown coming tomorrow
absolutely and i'm sure we all remember
incredibly
clearly what we were doing where we were
when the prime minister spoke on
that momentous occasion and the impact
the instant
impact it had that was becoming more and
more obvious
this was a really serious pandemic
schools were closed
but actually it was such a big thing and
there's so many things that we've now
taken for granted masks i mean we didn't
even wear masks a year ago and it took
months before it came in
home schooling the universities all shut
down all these things are just
life transforming and we've taken them
in our stride and it's been an awful
awfully tough year but actually there's
quite a lot of good things and we've had
great community spirit and there's lots
to celebrate so
it's just a massive milestone to look
back and in our own personal lives
realize really what we've accomplished
and what we've done as a country as a
world
yes and actually the the picture the
guardians chosen is
it is really poignant isn't it which is
a medical professional
holding the hands of a patient because
one of the other things we had to get
used to was
no visits to people who may not have
many days left of their life it's been
really astonishingly terrible for so
many people hasn't it
and your paper the star as well nancy uh
what a year with some of the
the numbers um that we're you know we're
still all enduring but
i suppose you know one good thing one
year on
um is that the the death rate really is
sinking now isn't it mark every every
death
is an absolute tragedy but back to
september figures now
um we must be heartened must we not by
the impact of the
of the vaccine rollout coupled with the
lockdown
indeed and exactly as nancy says it's
been a torrid and incredibly
tough year that's affected so many
people in so many
um really dreadful ways but it's also
been
a year in which people have proved so
resilient and
adaptable to these challenging
circumstances and one of the most
remarkable
adaptations we've seen mercifully is the
fastest ever development of a vaccine
like this the not just one but multiple
vaccines which are hugely
successfully effective saving people's
lives and preventing suffering
the rollout on an unprecedented scale
of those vaccines so many people already
saved by that but by that process and
all around the country
right now there are volunteers and
doctors and nurses and scientists
who are resting at the end of yet
another long day of protecting many
thousands more people and
thank goodness for them and just a quick
thought on your front page
um nancy uh you know one of the figures
that sprung out amongst all of them to
me
94.5 rising the number of people out of
work and on benefits
you know some of this still is
percolating through isn't it
um we we we've yet to see the full
impact for
for many households in some respects
even though people are saying
you know the roaring 20s are going to be
back with the amount of money that's
been saved
to get the economy going again but the
economic impact
is is there and all around us isn't it
absolutely and it is just going to grow
and i don't think we
quite understand or can anticipate the
scale of it yet
i mean that is a massive figure that
we've got twice the amount of people in
sheffield who are unemployed
but furlough hasn't finished has it and
it's quite away from being finished
so what will happen then i mean
optimistically we can hope can't with
that the bars and the restaurants and
places are back open
and people go for staycations and a lot
of
these jobs come back and actually maybe
even some new ones have
will be created but these are often
people
who are struggling anyway to make ends
meet they're not on great salaries
and actually this is devastating for
many many families so there is an awful
lot of work
we're at a point where we can celebrate
the vaccines but there's a lot of work
to be done to get people back on the
feet and to help the economy
in our individual cities but also as a
whole country uh meantime let's move on
to
um the sort of the pure vaccine news if
you like the metro
going on that really good study from
america uh on the astrazeneca vaccine
that looks specifically at some of the
clotting complaints we'd seen in europe
some of those concerns specifically
and the great efficacy rates as well and
many epidemiologists saying what a shame
this didn't report in january
and it might have calmed a lot of the
problems in europe which takes us also
to the eye which is the irish prime
minister backing the uk on vaccine
exports
um the prime minister been on doing sort
of a bit of
telephone diplomacy today and yesterday
not surprisingly
mark yes and it's
appalling really that it's even
necessary to do this you're right that
maybe it would have helped somewhat if
the u.s study had been back on the
astrazeneca
effects these results seen in the metro
no serious illnesses
no deaths among anybody in this trial
who
was in who took the astrazeneca vaccine
remarkable result
but that information if it had been
known in january would it have
prevented what we've seen from eu
leaders in the last couple of months
sadly i don't think it would because
there already was trial evidence there
already was
mass vaccination uh evidence that
already was clear study
um and a compelling case for this
vaccine that's why it was authorized in
the first place
the reason why eu leaders have been
behaving the way they have is not
because of
doubts about its efficacy but because of
a need to cover their backsides and
whether that's the still anonymous
german politicians who
untruly falsely briefed against the
efficacy of the the vaccine
whether it's emanuel macron who said
that it was a pseudo-effective in over
65
wrong again um whether it's the kind of
more recent panics and
or attacks on astrazeneca the company
this is not about
questions over the scientific evidence
it's about efforts to distract from the
incompetence
of some leaders who've got this very
badly wrong and that in itself is
shameful because it will cost lives well
health minister lord bethel raised the
prospect today of all of britain's
european neighbours being put on the
uk's
so-called travel red list which takes us
to the times nancy
overseas travel ban extended until july
the paper says
holidays will be banned until the end of
june
with people who try to leave the country
facing five thousand pound fines
as ministers tighten border restrictions
this came after boris johnson warned
today that the third wave in europe
would inevitably touch our shores i know
some people
um scientists that i follow uh have have
disputed that
but it certainly felt like he was laying
the groundwork for some
bad news on travel if i can put it that
way
well it does and it does feel like
what's happened in europe we've watched
in horror and then it's come to us so
actually i don't think we can criticize
for being
over cautious here i understand that
people want their holidays and i
understand that this has a huge
impact on the industry on
airplanes on your foreign well there's
just so many jobs involved
with it but we've got to get on top of
this pandemic we're in a really good
position now and we would be foolish to
throw that away so if that means that we
have to
stay in our own country if that means
that we have to go for holidays more
locally
i'm not sure that's the end of the world
it's certainly not worth risking
a potential third wave and if we can
control this is the right thing to do
the prime minister has been criticized
all the way along for reacting too
slowly
and he's he seems to have learned his
lesson we've we've got a
slow road map out of lockdown and now
we're having
a move to slow down people going on the
holidays you know what are some great
places in this country for staycations i
would suggest anybody comes up north
visit scotland
yorkshire there's some great
destinations if you don't want it
um there's a bot here in fact and you as
you say holidays in britain are banned
until at least april the 12th
uh when self-catering accommodation is
due to reopen um the bart in this
article as i read on because it's just
in
uh under draft laws published today to
implement johnson's roadmap out of
lockdown leaving the uk without a
reasonable excuse
such as work or education will be
illegal until june the 30th
people who travel from england to
another part of the uk with the aim of
leaving the country
or who go to an airport trying to do so
face fines of 5000
but officials stress that the travel ban
has been extended for legislative
convenience and does not preempt a
review of foreign travel
due next month so we will see um at the
moment it's may the 17th at the earliest
isn't it mark so
maybe this is just done as they say for
convenience of law
rather than actually the reality of what
might happen
yes the way these powers work
essentially is that the law
creates the the right for a ban to be in
place but ultimately it comes
it gives ministers the right to use
their discretion to set the rules in
with some degree of flexibility so there
is this official
global travel task force report that's
coming back i think on the 12th of april
and that is going to have a big a major
say in advising
the prime minister and other ministers
on exactly what to do i've got to say
the people i really feel for in this is
that we you know we all talk about this
just as being about holidays but of
course there are many many people
in this country who have family and
loved ones in
other countries who would be not
effectively going on holiday but
trying to see their loved ones
potentially for the first time in a year
or more and
i i really feel very very deeply for
them
the fact is as nancy says we don't know
exactly
uh what risks we're going to see with
this growing wave across
across many of our european neighbors
and that's obviously the reason why
this flexibility is being being extended
absolutely and as we know many places in
france for example
have brought in new lockdown
restrictions so
hopefully you know those efforts will
have an impact as well
we'll certainly delve into those
newspapers in more detail on travel and
elsewhere lots of people
lots of reasons why people try to go
abroad but coming up
china's retaliation to sanctions from
the us
eu uk and canada over its treatment of
uyghur muslims taking a look at that in
more detail
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
[Music]
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on the message
to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
[Applause]
we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made some arrests
already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone
they can't arrest everybody
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that
doesn't say hitler
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now editor of the
sheffield star nancy fielder
and the chief executive of conservative
home mark wallace welcome to both of you
um dominic raab stood in the comments
today mark did he not
talked about the uyghurs hours later uh
parliament decided to throw out plans to
uh stop trade if if uh genocide is
suspected it's it's a confusing picture
at times is it not
well i think there's a difference
between effect and process and the first
thing is
this move to use the magnitsky sanctions
these personal
targeted sanctions against human rights
abusers to use them against
chinese officials and authorities who
are responsible for the genocide being
perpetrated against the uyghurs
is really good news it's it's high time
i'm pleased about this i've been
pressing forward as have quite a lot of
other toy activists and various mps
and it's clear after last year when the
government introduced the magnetic
sanctions
power used it to start off against human
rights abusers in the
in the russian state but it should be
used against human rights abuses in
china
the second question is about process so
do you want to have
the rule on whether whether a state is
determined to be committing genocide do
you want it set by
a court or do you want it set by
parliament and that is a slightly more
kind of procedural debate i think
yes um she'll move on to nicola sturgeon
a smiling
face uh on the front of the preston
journal
the first minister relieved they say at
the watchdog verdict
uh tori's worn evidence against her is
still overwhelming pressing ahead
uh with a vote of confidence as well but
certainly this does stand here in good
stead does it not so far do you think
nancy
absolutely and she does look very
relieved in that photo and in all the
footage that we're seeing
um today she clearly has had a huge
weight lifted off her shoulders
but actually there is a long way to go
in this
and whatever the ultimate outcome this
has caused
devastation for her party it's damaged
her reputation is damaged the reputation
of her predecessor and it has brought
chaos where you might wonder actually
could have this been handled an
awful lot better so while she looks
happy today i think there were still
tough times ahead
indeed so and um should the tories be
pressing ahead with the vote of
confidence do you think mark
i think there might be pressing on the
topic i mean in addition to the people
who've been harmed by this that nancy
just mentioned
the women who were the original victims
of the
in these allegations have been
grievously let down and
scottish taxpayers have been let down
this process and anybody who wants to
see
the scottish government live up to its
claims about itself in terms of
how it governs how it does things this
has exposed all sorts of
frankly fundamental malfunctions at the
heart of the scottish government when
its institutions appear to be dominated
by the snp
well they have acknowledged that it
wasn't well handled doesn't mean that
actually
deliberate mistakes were made if you
know what i mean but uh you're gonna
she can't remember nicola tells us she
can't remember one way or the other
dozens of times and that in itself is a
bit of a problem i think
okay we'll we'll certainly pursue that
tomorrow there'll be lots more on that
uh
the report from the msps the vote etc uh
we will see two at half past eleven for
more thank you very much need nancy
fielder
and mark wallace